[Music]
in working girl news [ __ ] girl
submitted by double-dare you a woman's
subway selfie photo shoot went viral for
representing the peak of self-confidence
oh I think I heard about this with the
peep or the people of self-confidence
oh I saw this Ptak oh like this
represents what confidence looks like I
see but they obviously don't know Asian
people from Asia on the subway oh my god
I've seen Asian people not give a [ __ ]
so will be like this or whatever and
then I'm I'm in the frame I don't know
if that's confidence I would call it
oblivious or delirious but it's a
roomful of people we were in the airport
in Japan and then this guy was like in
Japan I'm not just like what the [ __ ]
are you doing and he was like was he
cute though
he's kinda cute maybe he was an
influencer already minute straight huh
maybe he was an influencer maybe but
that's pretty confident cuz I'm like
damn this will just keep that's that's
pretty confident so sure why'd she do it
on the subway okay so this guy named Ben
there's good depth of field tweeted this
out and he captioned it with this woman
this woman giving it all to the selfie
cam on the train is sending me and so
the video is this yeah I didn't even
know what she was doing I thought she
was dancing or something and she was
drunk she was taking selfies
she's myself though she chopped that's
what I thought is it 10 a.m. or the 10
p.m. or 2 a.m.
so wireless remote turn
Wow
she says
she looks like she's dressed for work
I want to see what the results Meatwad
they were
and you get to see the view
all she found on hell yeah so then been
tweeted that out right and so she ended
up hey the Bendel's recording it the guy
getting saddle oh yeah he got the he had
sent yes so then it went viral there was
there's over eight million views Wow on
Twitter how people were able to find her
she found out about this somehow so she
ended up saying thank you sir on Twitter
Wow Wow great picture go back oh wait
this one there we go
okay head why in the back look at the
lady of the back
she's like feeling herself to - Wow does
she posted these after like in the
thread she's like thank you sir
and then to just get getting a lot of
positive feedback and I ended up saying
I am overwhelmed by the kind words
expressed by everyone and I just want to
say thank you to all let's spread this
positivity and continue to uplift one
another oh and shout out to Ben for
making my date hashtag NYC hashtag does
she have a lot of followers now good
George a million maybe I think you 8,000
because that the drop-off is insane I've
seen that happen a lot yeah we're like
something goes viral and then the person
tries to like hey I'm selling shirts
it's like it's the best I like it when
they always promoting some [ __ ] like oh
hey follow my Instagram or whatever and
I'm like no one actually follows right
it's like my Instagram you're on the
subway out no sorry
gone they're already gone so she has
almost 30k on Twitter now I don't know
how much she started with but 30 days a
lot I'm tired yeah on Twitter versus 8
million I do not do that [ __ ] I would be
so embarrassed
yeah everyone is saying like ones like
I'm just like oh take one picture like
let's go and it's my job to like host of
on Instagram sometimes are you envious
for confidence not really because no
like I can take pictures in the prime I
like privacy it depends on what day
she's doing that if I was in New York I
so live in here
and if I was taking the subway and it
was crowded it looks like it was maybe
at night like well if you tweeted this
at 3 p.m. okay so it wasn't crowded
she had space I feel like she wasn't
bothering anyone but I could see people
being like are you [ __ ] kidding me in
New York City in the like rush-hour
traffic because it's so should be a bit
of ways yeah she would be a big [ __ ]
they didn't look crowded there
dude you should see people I do this
stupid day on Instagram where I take
selfies of myself so so you should see
when people are reacting to that while
I'm in a public place usually where at
some Instagram what can help what does
it look like it's doing so I'm always
doing like you make noise all the [ __ ]
we had helped me do that stupid face
right but then there's people watching
who are like like what an idiot and and
it's so it's very fun for me to see
their faces after I do it and I just
treat it a little bit a no straight face
afterward like you know I mean like I
put it away and I put my face back on
it'll do they know well I think it's
important to do that because sometimes
I've had photos where I'm like with my
boyfriend or something we're in front of
like how recent is this how easily a
couple months ago okay wow you should
have said John say for sure but we'll be
in a nice place and we want to take a
picture and I'm just like no it's good
like whatever it is it's good like
that's what we got but I wish I picture
would have been a little bit better of
me yeah so do you blogger Lovelace I
don't log and I stopped doing that
vlogging like finish logging because I
don't like people looking at me yeah so
when you're vlogging you feel like eyes
are on you you're like I feel like that
vlogger douchebag yeah sure
that's my problem I think this is great
that she's feeling confident how about
um is your fiance an influencer I know
nobody else produced some of myself most
myself like come on I'm oh honey do it
do it
you're doing them all kinds of dirty in
this video I think both of us are kind
of don't like attention attention in
that way like personal attention that's
kind of why we don't have a wedding
because when we got engaged my friend
was like I told the waiter that you guys
were just engaged and she's gonna bring
you a drink and she brought me a drink
and I'm like no great now I have to
[ __ ] tip this [ __ ] more because she
brought me a freed right you're going a
little extreme what happens when you run
into a fan too like we did with a thank
you to them oh well no I also feel very
obligated to be like oh man I gotta tip
them even bigger now because they're
gonna be like oh [ __ ] geo me gave me
like the [ __ ] 10% tip you know and
said my tip is my entertainment - yes
I'll give you free videos [ __ ]
no I feel you though I'm like a hundred
percent like that like I love her
confidence and for me at least it's not
a matter of confidence it's more like I
just don't want people looking at me
like I don't want to be like the center
of attention I'm if anything I'm trying
to like blend into the wall as much as I
can so I don't I could never do that
yeah I feel like that's most people come
judging by all the responses in this and
Twitter on Twitter they're saying that
you know it's so crazy that she has all
this confidence to do it in front of
others this is powerful I could never
but then other people are like powerful
or completely inconsiderate that the
other passengers maybe don't want to be
a prop in her sex pics seriously get a
room sex pigs come on man but if it's
for her private snapchat Oh jerk-off
snapchat has like zero cleavage showing
yeah no she looks like she's about to go
to the office
maybe it's like yeah the beginning snap
of the Christmas I'm going to work now
and in the second snap is gonna be her
like naked in the bathroom or something
that's pretty good girl what happened to
the middle yeah I guess from the train
to the bathroom she's one boob there
yeah at the office it's two boobs okay
someone else said she gives zero [ __ ]
she's [ __ ] she's serving
damn that's a [ __ ] she's LCC she's
very [ __ ] and then another one says
obviously a millennial millennial [ __ ]
hater
another one is I'm completely focused on
her touching that train seat and
handlebar and then touching her face and
hair she braved bacteria for a solid
selfie and that's the real story here oh
haters but she's not hurting anyone
she's not killing it
yes god I was doing it by yourself I
feel like I've done worse yeah different
orders like dudes Alois what I mean we I
mean come on like we ran into businesses
and [ __ ] filmed there and and I
pushed him and he fell on a lady and she
screamed and like well this was like ten
years ago or so but uh before you get
cancelled yeah you make it sound way
more dramatic I think he kind of just
like lightly grazed the woman yeah and
we also chased each other around the
plaza
ran into businesses in costumes I was
Superman and he was my villain the
[ __ ] and then yeah yeah and then he
jumped inside of a fountain and to get
away from me and and he was swimming in
the in the public fountain and this is
pretty funny today
no wait fast these old guys know cuz you
guys were younger after the fountain we
was the camera guy like we got it was
another camera guy kept running into the
parking lot yeah what their sweat shoes
you [ __ ] stupid [ __ ] that's why I'm
like I don't know can I blame people
doing I got no hate for her yeah no I
mean I got hate for people giving hate
to her but that's the thing about
Twitter man it's like an art gallery of
like like come and throw your [ __ ]
interpretation of this up and most
people are like it's like an art gallery
where everyone sees darden they go [ __ ]
you it's like [ __ ] you alright you go
girl
yeah I wish I could do that too very few
though it's a it's a it's a projection
[ __ ] vomit
yeah yeah you know I didn't read this in
the replies but saying how society is
these days I'm surprised I didn't read
someone saying like how could you take
film her without her permission and I
put
for the public to scrutinize her it's
New York though it's not California
right California has a law where you can
only you have to have someone's consent
but New York I don't think you need that
I don't know if you needed for a public
place ethical things yeah internet
social justice stuff mm-hmm true yeah
well she seemed to be down with it yeah
she's pretty happy feedback usually when
you see that there's like four other
girls like yeah
yeah go go uh-huh I'm posing you and
like making sure you're looking sick she
just has a selfie cam yeah the brave
part is alone doing it a lot it's the
difference the braver part she was using
that [ __ ] timer you know y'all
[ __ ] long wait for that you're like
well that fish is kind of moving like
when you have to go back in it yeah
exactly what was it a laptop er was a
cell phone phone that'd be funny if she
had a laptop dude I thought I was a
laptop cuz it could stand by its own
[ __ ] webcam and [ __ ] if you want to
see some annoying poses go right now -
there's Abbey Road Studios you can see
where the Beatles took that port picture
of them crossing the street people are
there right now and somebody's honking
at them and they're going like trying to
walk like the Beatles get home dad I
still think of the picture you can watch
it right now I'm not even kidding you
can watch it live on camera check it out
[Music]